so I claimed in the last video that we
made a five-dollar risk-free profit by
spending thirty-eight dollars to buy a
call and a bond and we got $43 by
shorting a stock and essentially writing
a put option what I want to do in this
video is verify that we really do have
all of our bases covered so let's just
think about all of the different
scenarios for the underlying stock price
at option expiration because that's the
date that we care about so let's take
the situation where the stock just
becomes where the stock just goes to
zero so in that situation the call that
we own is worthless the call is
worthless no reason why you would want
to exercise the option to buy it for $35
when the stock is worth zero but the
good thing is is that we when we now
have to cover our short remember when
you short something you're borrowing the
stock and selling it and in the future
you have to buy the stock to cover your
short to buy the stock and return it to
whomever you borrowed it from so now we
can spend $0 we can now spend $0 $0 to
buy stock and essentially give it back
to whom we borrowed it from or
essentially cover the short to buy stock
to cover or unwind short to cover the
short the bad thing is is that put
option that we wrote remember we wrote
it we sold the put option we're giving
someone else the right to sell to sell
the stock to us for $35 and if the stock
price is worth the 0 they're going to
exercise that option because they can
then they can buy the stock for 0 they
can sell it to us for $35 so we have to
spend we have to spend $35 to buy to to
kind of buy the stock from put holder
from put holder but the good thing is is
that we have this bond we own this bond
that's not worth $35 we have a $35 bond
35 we have a $35 bond so we can use the
$35 bond to to spend the $35 and since
you give that $35 to the holder of the
put and everything cancels out so we can
still keep
original $5 so that's the situation
where the stock price went to zero what
about the situation where the stock
price goes to something crazy let's say
the stock price goes to 70 so the stock
price goes up let me draw a little
column over here so now let's think
about the scenario where the stock price
goes to 70 now all of a sudden the call
option we have remember it's an option
to buy the stock at $35 the call the
call is worth is worth $35 the call is
worth $35 we have a bond that's going to
be worth $35 a bond worth 35 the put
option is worthless so the person who we
get who we wrote the put forth they
won't exercise it so the put is
worthless the put is worthless but we
still have to cover our short we have to
buy back the stock and return the stock
to whomever we borrowed it from and now
to cover our short to buy the stock it's
going to cost us $70 so we're going to
have to use this $70 so $35 from the
call and $35 from the bond to actually
cover our short position so $70 to buy
stock and cover short and what you'll
see is I just picked kind of a low a low
stock price and a high stock price but
no matter what the stock price is you're
going to be able to cover all of your
obligations and break even at expiration
and keep your original risk free $5 now
the reality of the situation is that
opportunities like the seldom exist
because frankly people can write
computer programs to find these these
arbitrage opportunities and just exploit
them really really really fast